- Oh crap!
Oh God!
I like really white.
("Bright Size" by Warner /
Chappell Production Music)
(sign creaking)
- Beautify.
Does that imply that I'm
not already beautful?
- Skin. That's a weird option to have.
- I kind of already predicted
what was gonna happen.
I'm gonna get super pale.
- Wait, there's a filter called whitening?
Where's the tanning filter?
- Okay, we'll go all
the way with the white
since my mom would appreciate that.
She doesn't like me being tan.
- Oh my God! (laughs dramatically)
I look like a ghost.
- A lot of people in India
like to use skin lighteners
but I think dark skin is really pretty.
- Definitely, just
stripped my browness away.
- Oh my God, my skin looks
so much better. (laughs)
- Select the area you wanna stretch.
I don't wanna stretch anything out.
- It kinda just made my boob bigger
which I don't know how I feel about that.
- Oh, my face was this big beforehand?
- Oh my God.
Look at my cheeks.
- Tap to remove acne.
All right. Well, I was PMS-ing this week,
so I know exactly where I'm breaking out.
- Wait, only take this mole.
Oh my God!
It's just like lifting my moles away.
- I'm basically like doing
plastic surgery virtually
on my face right now.
- Like I predicted, there
was an eye enlargening tool.
- Do a lot of people want bigger eyes?
Because it's its own ... (gasps)
- Oh my God!
This is like so much cheaper than surgery.
- I look like an alien.
- The difference is so
subtle but also so noticeable
when you look at the before and after.
- Oh no. (laughs loudly and squeals)
- Okay, I'm gonna hit auto retouch
and I'm kind of super
nervous to see what happens.
So ...
Oh my God! (laughs loudly)
Oh my God! I look ridiculous.
- It's weird because the
longer you look at it,
the more normal it looks and
that's really terrifying.
- This is just ...
It's not me.
- This app definitely shows
how different the beauty standards are
here compared to Asia.
- I feel like an American version of this
would probably, like, make
your eyebrows on fleek.
- There would definitely be a tool
that would give you like
big full Kylie Jenner lips.
- I think the biggest
difference is that people
in Asia want lighter skin apparently.
- I don't think I'd use it to fix myself
or make myself more beautiful in an image
but it was fun to play with and
I would play it like a game.
- I am half Indian and I have dark skin
and I wouldn't trade it for anything.
- I mean, it's not you
at the end of the day.
I mean, the picture is supposed to be you.
("Bright Size" by Warner /
Chappell Production Music)
- [African-American woman] I
like how the Kardashian clan
is basically, America's
standard of beauty.
Like the whole family
has some kind of trait
that we're all trying to, like, emulate.